that event that we went to was great the
who played mhm Green Day Billy Idol yeah
and then John Fogerty I love John
Fogerty I loved it John Fogerty was like
you see him and you're like oh yeah
that's great some c songs all of a
sudden oh one hit another hit we just
know every single song so well that's I
grew up to that song I thought the Green
Day drummer was amazing cuz where we
were standing I didn't really I've never
really focused on the drumming yeah but
I was standing beside you and we were
standing backstage and I watched him and
he was a like an incredible showman but
it was like I would imagine I don't know
that much about the intricacy of music
but the drum drives he's great he really
is he is he known in the drumming
Community is he yeah definitely who's
your favorite drummer do you have a drum
hero yeah I'll go through a list of them
Clen Burke from Blondie is my favorite
really yeah Burke from Blondie yeah and
then Keith Moon from the who oh wow yeah
love Keith Moon that's a really short
list yeah you said I'm going to go
through a list and you just had a list
you but I wasn't done I wasn't done with
the list sorry sorry oh okay sorry how
long is the list because I just want to
60 drummers oh sorry and I and I
talk real slow okay 60 drummers
Ringo really is yeah it's Simplicity
right is that he's he so he's so
expressive didn't they were isn't didn't
they have another
drummer P best P best yeah yeah who was
not who was not simplistic no he wasn't
the best but he was the he left I think
they just didn't have chemistry with him
or something can you imagine being Pete
best that's got to be a great story
somebody has to do a Pete best I bet you
they've tried I bet you someone's tried
to write a book or I bet you there is a
book out or something cuz that's in that
that's really can you M for those that
don't know and I think there probably
two but Pete best was the drummer and
left and then Ringo joined and that was
I think he was he was kicked out he
kicked out he was kicked out yeah I'm
when I say for those that don't know I
was including myself in the list hello
okay hello okay wasn't he also better
looking too than them oh manbe wasn't
that part of it too he was more of like
a heartthrob I wasn't there but I'll
guess that
[Music]
he